forscherinnen und forscher befürchten
eine alien-invasion wenn david baker
sein metier projekt durch zb die steht
dabei für messaging extraterrestrial
intelligence also so viel wie
nachrichten an außerirdische
intelligenzen der mann will in großem
stil nachrichten ins all senden um
endlich mit aliens in kontakt zu treten
doch viele warnen vor solch einem
eigenmächtigen schritt jetzt wirklich
vom feinsten fixen herzlich willkommen
ja wir hatten das thema schon mal hier
doch jetzt wird es konkret angegangen
beim letzten mal ging es um die signale
die wir mit atombombentest und dem
funkverkehr zwischen boten ins weltall
aus gesendet haben und damit vielleicht
feindlich gesinnte außerirdische zu uns
gelockt haben die mobbing warm vor der
kontaktaufnahme mit denen er vergleicht
die mehr kontakt mit der entdeckung
amerikas die urbevölkerung wurden dort
fast vernichtet und die europäer nahmen
den gesamten kontinent ein laut hawking
würde genau das auch mit einer spezies
passieren wie uns einige milliarden
jahre voraus sein könnte wenn wir uns
unter umständen nicht freundlich
gesinnt wären dann wären wir ein
leichtes viel und sie müssen uns dabei
nicht mal feindlich gesinnt sein
das medi projekt wird jetzt ganz konkret
mit einer erklärung angegangen die
unter anderem auch von ihnen musk
unterzeichnet worden ist
in der erklärung wird gewarnt dass
nahezu uns lebende aliens unsere
radiosignale den weltraummüll und so
weiter und so fort aufgespürt haben
könnten aber dass immer noch
schwieriger ist als ein gezieltes signal
abpfiff und wie hoch waren sie vor
außerirdischen wir wissen nichts über
die intentionen und fähigkeiten und es
ist unmöglich vorherzusagen ob sie gut
artig oder feindlich gestimmt sind aber
warum gibt es jetzt so einen aufruhr um
medicopter gab es ja schon versuche
kontakt zu ihnen aufzunehmen verteilen
70 schickte die nasa die pioneer 10 und
19 73 die pioneer 11 mit einer botschaft
in den weltraum 1977 dann beute 1 und 2
und mozart 74 wurde vom arecibo
radioteleskop die arecibo botschaft
ausgesendet die idee hatte der
astrophysiker frank drake der auch die
drake formel entwickelt hat mit ihr kann
man ausrechnen wieviele außerirdische
zivilisationen sich in aller
galaxie befinden allerdings wenn die
faktoren in der formel von so vielen
umständen und schätzungen abhängig
dass die ergebnisse höchst
unterschiedlich sind für unsere galaxie
schwank das ergebnis zwischen zwei und
vier millionen zivilisation ist er ist
auf jeden fall von der existenz von
aliens überzeugt und dachte sich
deshalb diese nachricht aus wie wurde in
den kugelsternhaufen im breitling
gewendet in rund 25.000 jahren wird die
botschaft dort ankommen so dass wir in
50.000 jahren mit einer nachricht
rechnen können wenn es uns dann noch
gibt alles nur pille fit sagt
astrophysiker und mitgründer jay koch
er will das projekt in großem stil
angehen wenn wir außerirdische wirklich
mit einem signal erreichen wollen dann
müssen wir es richtig machen er will am
2018 ein signal zu proxima centauri bebt
oder zugleich 111 schicken
wieso ein paar lichtjahre entfernt und
sie könnten neben der wagen beide
umkreisen ihren heimatstern in der
habitablen zone also in der bewohnbaren
zone wo ich leben geben kann und es
könnte deshalb eben also auch
tatsächlich intelligentes leben dort
leben und wenn koch will noch etwas
anderes machen nicht nur die gezielte
auswahl der empfänger gehört zu seiner
idee sondern auch die dauer
sie soll nämlich erstmal nicht enden
eine dauerhafte sendung der signal für
den beiden planeten und auch die
nachricht selbst soll durchdachter als
die bisherigen seien keine bilder keine
töne sondern mathematik weil koch geht
davon aus dass auch dort wie beim wg
projekt hier auf der erde
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nach signalen suchen eine sprache
würden sie also in jedem fall verstehen
die der mathematik beginnen würde die
botschaft mit zwei signalen wird eine
dauer zwei sekunden und das nächste
drei sekunden
dann folgt ein fünfstündiges signal
addition ich bin sehr gespannt wie
dieses projekt in die tat umgesetzt wird
viel finden dass ein solches projekt
eine erlaubnis der menschheit der uno
benötigt aber bitte bisher gibt es
keine entsprechenden regelung was man
ihr schreibt es in die kommentare ich
halte euch natürlich hier zum thema auf
dem laufenden wenn er kein video dazu
verpassen
dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
unvergesslich den
auf die glocke ja hier geht es weiter
mit müssen wir einen alien angriff
fürchten mit noch mehr infos zum thema
wenn es euch interessiert dann umwegen
draufklicken und ansonsten das land
bleibt preis